good evening ladies and gentlemen uh my
question for you guys is the last few
weeks have shown that our immigration
system doesn't actually work is the
government so proud to acknowledge that
i want to put that to our panel a second
andrea but what um what leads you to ask
that question
what's in your own experience
well we're looking at everywhere in uk
especially if we're looking at the
poultry
industries or
um farmers we know that these such sort
of businesses 80 percent of them are
european and we know they might not be
the brightest ones as the government
tends to
label the brightest and the the best but
we all need them are we going to go
hungry
because of that
okay thank you andrea um
i want to go to
another
member in our wall i think ray price has
been
already uh waving to get into the
conversation ray i think people see
britain as somewhere it's a bit like the
dickwitted and story is london paved
with gold
on i don't think it is
and we're asking and issuing visas for 5
000 truck drivers that probably within
the last 18 months we have told most of
them to go home and now that we stuck we
want them back
but um a lot of those people want to
come and they work i mean it's not like
they want to come and hang about in the
streets do they
well i think if you look at places like
london and statistically the crime rates
have gone up the beggars on the street
um it seems to be a lot of foreign
influence where ethnicity plays a part
um there are a lot of european eastern
europeans coming to britain
with no intention of working whatsoever
i'm more than happy for people to work
in this country i have no problem at all
but contribute to the country
all right um
let's go to northern ireland now
janine moody
what do you make of what um ray has just
said
uh about
britain being a softer touch
totally agree
yeah i mean you wanted to look at the
australian model and i mean the way they
operate is that
they have targeted immigration for
example
based on the needs of the economy a
brain surgeon could get less points than
a hairdresser
because that's where the need is they
need whatever they i think it needs to
be targeted as opposed to like a cuda
system just to please everyone in europe
you know let's just bring everyone in
just so that we're seen to be helping
you know the x number of thousand people
we need a structure and it needs
leadership we need leadership
from the government and we need to be to
find out what our economy needs okay
because our hospitals are already
waiting less we can't take our systems
are broken
we will come back to some of that a bit
later but
thank you janine let's go back to
andrea's original questions started our
show recent weeks have shown our
immigration system doesn't work is the
government
too proud to change it theopa fetus i
think immigration has been a wonderful
thing for the united kingdom if it
wasn't for the fact that my parents came
in 66
low-skilled labor which was required at
the time and they contributed and it's
the second general i'm second generation
i was born in cyprus i suppose i'm first
generation but i'm their offspring i've
contributed i employ people so what are
we going to do are we going to
shut our doors and say you know what
we're going to shut everything down
we're not going to get deliveries to
supermarkets we're not going to have any
nurses we're not going to have any
doctors because we don't want these
foreigners to come here the reality is
it's about we've left break we've left
the eu
so when we left the eu is about one of
the things was controlled immigration so
we have now the ability the government
has the ability to control immigration
so we should have stopped slowing finish
we must stop talking about uncontrolled
immigration that's not true but i have
controlled immigration now but right now
theo you've got what 4 000 employees
also in your businesses
is the immigration policy the that we
have now the right one for your
businesses well we don't know what it is
we just we just say 1970s comedians
catch phrases no more uncontrolled
immigration no more cheap labor we want
upskill labor so someone who picks fruit
it doesn't matter how much you upskilled
them they'll still pick fruit